Let's think about what's going on
with the median and average values ​​of a given set of numbers,
when changing one of the numbers.
Let's take a look at this example.
A group of four friends like to play puzzles together,
each recording the highest score of all
for a game.
Their highest scores are between 180 and 220,
except for Adam, whose highest score is 250.
Then Adam makes a great game
and achieved a new highest score of 290.
How the rise in Adam's highest score will affect the average
and the median?
Now, as always, stop the video paused
and see if you can find this yourself.
Let's think about what has been said.
We have four friends,
each recording the highest score,
so we will have 4 data points,
the highest score for each of your friends.
Let's see, this is the lowest score of all friends,
this is the second lowest, the second highest
and this is the highest score of friends.
Let's see.
Their highest scores are between 100 and 220,
except for Adam, whose highest score is 250.
Before Adam played this amazing game,
the results look similar.
The lowest score is 180.
Adam notes 250.
And if you take Adam out of the picture,
the highest score is 220.
And we do not really know what this result is
right there.
Now that Adam is playing a great new game
and has a new highest score of 290,
how will the set of data look like?
Well, this man's highest score has not changed.
This friend's highest score has not changed.
But now Adam has a new highest score.
Instead of 250, he is now 290.
So my question is,
the first question is how does the median change?
Well remember that the median is the average number.
And if we look at the four numbers here,
the median will be the average
of the two members in the middle.
So we'll get the average
from what we have in place of this question mark and 220.
This will be the median.
Once Adam scored a new highest score,
how do we calculate the median?
Well, we still have 4 numbers
and the middle two are still the same two mean numbers.
Whatever the friend's highest score, he has not changed,
so we will have the same median.
We will have 220 plus a question mark divided by 2.
It will be half the question mark and 220.
So the median
does not change.
The median does not change.
Let us now think about the average value.
Well, at the average we have the sum of all these numbers
and then divide to 4.
Then we take the sum
of all these numbers and divide it into 4.
Which sum will be higher?
Ok, the first 3 numbers are the same,
but you have a larger number in the second list.
290 is greater than 250.
So if we take these 4 numbers and divide them into 4,
you will have more value,
than if you take these 4 and divide them at 4,
because their sum will be larger.
So the average value will go up.
Avarage value
will grow.
So the median does not change, and the mean grows.
Well, here they say they both grow. No, that's not true.
The median will grow. No, the median does not change.
The average will increase. Yes.
And the median will remain the same.
Yes, that's exactly the same we talked about.
And if you want to do it a little more specifically,
you can replace the question mark with a number.
Perhaps this question mark is 200.
And if you try 200,
to make things specific, you will see that
this will really be the case.
The median will be half of those two numbers.
As I randomly chose 200.
It can be any number found
between 180 and 220,
but you see that for this example
it is very clear that the median does not change.
But the average value increases because we increase the sum.
We increase the sum by 40,
because we have increased
the last number by 40.